Thank you for that wonderful introduction,
that once expected.
Yes, hello, I'm James, I'm going to talk to
you today about practical functional programming,
to make sure I get through this in plenty
of time, and the clock's not ticking down,
so I don't know how much time I've got, that's
very confusing.
What do I mean by functional programming?
Well, initially I didn't even know, itches
looking for ideas to talk about on Twitter
a while ago, and Jan gave this idea, practical
function fallal programming, and I brushed
it off with a little juke.
Got me thinking.
It has first class functions, and we have
venttion and call backs and we have all the
array operations like map, filter, reduce
and stuff like that.
But, there's a lot more to functional programming
than we often acknowledge.
And what I would like to do is sort of demystify
that a little bit.
Because one criticism of functional programming,
it's not very practical and you need a PhD
to understand it.
What I'd like to do is sort of talk about
the ways in which we are already using functional
ideas in mainstream JavaScript and how we
can pay better attention to those and get
better value out of them.
Also promise the last occurrence of the word
Monad in this talk, there's not going to be
a lot of type theory stuff going on.
What do we mean by functions?
Functional programming is about programming
without side effects, if you're in the Parallel
JavaScript talk earlier you would have heard
that side effects are one of the biggest barriers
to parallelizing a program because you can't
reason about changes to a global state, makes
it hard to parial rise things.
What does it look like to program functionally.
You want to calculate the length of a list,
length takes a list and returns an Int that's
what that little type signature means.
So, what you could do is set the counter to
0 and increment the counter for every iment
and return the last value of the counter.
How does that run out in practice, want to
get the value of the list, set the count to
zero, first element, increment the index,
there's a second element, we increment, there's
a third, we increment, there's no fourth element
we break the loop and induction is 3.
The values of the index comments‑‑ those
aren't statements that appear anywhere in
the program that state you have to keep in
your head while you figure out what the program
dugs, that's what makes imperative programs
hard to reason about.
A functional version would look like this,
cough free script has three dot syntax that
breaks a list into the first elements and
the rest of the elements.
If the first element is undefined the list
is empty, right, so it has length 0 otherwise
the length one plus the length of the rest
of the list, we're doing a recuresive break
down.
What does that look like in practice, so,
there is a first element, so we'll pick a
second bunch.
We're just going to replace the definition,
we're using it as a rewrite rule, no implicit
state to keep track of.
We do that a couple more times then we get
length of the empty list, which we pick the
first branch of the conditional, which is
0 and result falls out.
So here rather than writing comments with
sate in them, I've written "is" before each
expression, that's because they're identical.
Doesn't mean they have the same value at a
particular point in time, they always have
the same value you can replace any of these
expression with any of the other and the program
will do the same thing.
Substituting bitting of source code for each
other makes it easy to think about, you don't
have to track state somewhere else in your
mind or on paper.
Let's take another function, map, the signature
means map takes a function from A to B and
a list of As and returns a list of Bs, the
imperative version of that would be to take
an empty list and push ever VEX for every
element in the input and return the list.
The functional version would be to say in
is no first element, the effect is undefined
then return an empty list otherwise afully
F to the first element and then combine that
with map over the rest of the list.
Same structure as we're doing the went, we're
using list instead of numbers, say we want
to square the first three numbers, we go,
there is a first element, so we'll take a
second branch, so square of one is one, we
pull that out of the front and map over what's
left, map over what's left, square two and
then, we have anmentty list, and so, the‑‑
an empty list and then the result falls out.
These are our functional solutions to the
problem, theye they work by not my stating
the state, they work by giving you an expression
you're trying to calculatend that you can
replace and you do that recursively.
You can program by substitution by using these
things.
The imperative solutions work by making some
state and then like changing that state until
some condition becomes true and then handing
that state off to you at the end.
But even though those have internal state
and they're not internally functional, they
do exactly the same thing as these versions,
because,‑‑ they don't Mutate‑‑
you can treat them as if they're the same
functions.
That's useful, it means their state is completely
ensuelated the sidefects continue leek out
into the rest of the program.
We use that in promises.
Promises have internal state, they are pending
and they can become fulfilled or rejected
with a value or an error.
But, every time you call then it will yield
the same value to you, you never get to see
what's actually going on inside of the promise,
Jo us call then and value pops out and it's
always the same value you can treat a promise
as an immutable value, which is useful.
A couple weeks ago too much ash ford had this
really good essay, vents are bad primitive
for data flow, they require distribution of
mutable state around your code and it's not
idiomatic or plea Saint to flow through data
through events.
We can use types to answer that question,
if we consider the FS.read file, that takes
a path name, an encoding, a call back and
it returns nothing, and the call back is itself
a function that takes an error, value and
alts returns nothing.
Now function that returns nothing must have
side effects because if a function has no
return value and no sidefects what why you
calling it?
It's not doing anything.
The thing that you think of not having side
effects is reading a file we work with these
things using side effects functions, completely.
When we're dealing with all these asynchronous
things all the time we have to make sure all
the side effects happen in the right order
so the program doesn't get into a bizarre
state, and trying to did that on concurrent
programs is very, very difficult, which you
doubt know.
It gets even harder when you try odo a lot
of things at same time, if you want to read
a file and request a URL and get something
out of a data business at the same time, you
use Async.parallel, and do operation, when
they complete you get a cull back and you
get value for those things, what would I do
if I wanted to get the value of the file before
the other things are completed and do something
with it.
Because this, if any of the things fail, I
won't get any of the values, I only work on
the file even if the HDP request fails, I
could pull the file operation out top.
I have an FS.read file‑‑ but now I've
made the program slower because the second
thing are blocked on the first thing completing,
so I de‑parol liesed it.
That kills the performance, it's convenient,
but, you've traded convenience for performance.
What you actually have do is keep the parallel
construct to make sure the IO happens at the
same time but plug your processing into the
bit where the file is requested, the more
you do these things the data processing, what
you're forced do by the way that we schedule
things in asynchronous programs your programs
get very messy, edge tangled you get into
what we
roll call
back hell, it's not a sin tackic thing about
your code creeping across the page, it's the
inability to reason able when things are happening
in your program and make sure they happen
as efficiently as possible, to do this you
is to construct your program in a very specific
way with call backs in all the right places.
So, last year I read this article called call
backs are imperative, promises are functional,
which had this quote "the future of promises
is that they remain immune to change circumstances."
I've already mentioned that‑‑ I got
some laughs‑‑ I already mention how
promises look like immutable values because
then always gives you the same result out
once the tasks are completed, but this is
also true in a second way that I department
realize at the same, the promises that deal
in changing promises much more easily.
Before when I was using the asing module I
had to change my program quite radically,
I could make a big structural change to it
to make quite a small requirement change.
But say those functions return promises my
FS.read and database dot get always return
promises of strings, I can call all those
functions and put the results in an array
and all the Io will just happen in parallel,
but now I have an array of promises of strings.
And if I want just the first‑‑ if I
just want the file out of that, then I can
get the first promise out of the list and
do something with the result.
If I want to wait for all of the things to
finish, then I can call promise.all with the
documents and I get a promise that will give
me all of the results when they're ready,
if I don't want to deal with the file on it's
own, I just delete the documents.zero line,
I can just add lines for those, I don't have
to make bige structural changes to my program.
You keep the ability to keep your IO happening
in parallel, but you keep the convenience
of being able to work with it easily, that's
really important for dealing with programs
that change a lot over time.
And the reason this works is that I can ask
for the value out of the file promise and
promise to all can also answer the value out
of that file promise, and it'll work both
times because you can keep asking for the
value over and over again, and you won't repeat
any work, what it means to be immutable, it's
rejuiceble, right.
So let's talk‑‑ it's reusable.
We talk about I in very imperative terms,
we say then takes a function and that function
will be invoked when the task completes with
the value of the task, if it's completed it
will be invoked with the value of the task
it returns a promise and that promise will
be invoked with the return of the call back,
we talk about then, do this, then do this,
and then do that.
But if you think about the types of things
that are involved, what then really does it
takes a promise of A and function there A
to B and returns a promise of B, if we have
a promise of a string and we call then with
a function that counts the word in a string,
string.split on spaces.length what we get
is a promise of an I Int, we might not have
the Int, but that's the type of the value
we have, we continue to do more processing
on it, transform it into another thing, transform
it into another thing, and use the promise
itself as a value, not the thing that's inside
of it.
This is exactly the same thing a ray.map works
it takes list of something and a function
from A to B around returns a list of B, right,
so if you have a list of strings and you map
a word counting function over the list, you
now have a list of word counts just as if
you called then with a word counting function
you turn a promise of a string into a promise
of a word count, a promise is just a container,
it's a list, they're the same thing, the operations
are the same thing, a container of up type,
container of another type with a mapping function
between them, and because they're just containertion
you can compos containers, they're just another
type of data structure, if you have a list
of promise of strings you turn that into a
list of promises of Int by mapping over the
array this is no different than mapping over
nested array you have two maps inside of one
another.
Promise to all is the same, we talk at promise
to all as in you give it a bunch of promises
as input then it will give you one promise
when it resolve, we talk about it in time
terms, if you talk about it in type terms,
it turns a container inside out you give it
a list of promises and it gives you a promise
of a list, you get one promise back that will
give you a list of all of the things.
This also solves the Zaga‑‑ Zalg oproblem,
personification of the problem with writing
call back APIs that will execute a call back
synchronously or asynchronously.
A equals Null promise.then X equals data equals
X on statement before line three otherwise
your program won't work, if it ran asin concurrent
resolution noselite would break.
The only reason it's a problem is because
you have side effect, you care about things
happening in a certain order something that's
been changed into another state before another
statement runs, if instead you do your process
inside of the promise construct you don't
think of a promise as a thing to get value
out of you think of it as a value on it's
own that you can do commutation inside of,
then that problem goes away.
Want to talk about laciness, another big topic
in functional programming (Lazi iness) I want
to show you a little bit of Hasckell code‑‑
Haskell code.
Cough free script is written as a colon, first
element colon, the rest of the elements.
So map we've already seen, map of an Ety list
is an empty list,and map in the general case,
you apply F to X and combine that to map over
the rest of the list, it looks weird but we
saw it working in coffee script, filter works
pretty much the same way, filter of an empty
list is an empty list, where peer Cex is true
you keep X you you combine with the filter
of the rest of the list otherwise you throw
X away and keep the rest of the list, we keep
X braced on whether the predicate is true
for the value.
Take, first and end elements of allis, take
where N is less than 0 you don't want to take
any more data, take of an empty list because
there's no more day the to take, so empty,
then take in a general case, you pop the first
element and take N minus one of what's left
and apply that recuresively the value will
fall out.
This lets you do somethinger, very powerful.
Haskell has infinite data structure, list
of ..., is to infinity, the filter would never
return, it tries to process the whole array
at once, looks what happen in Haskel, I'm
going to program by replacing functioncal
with the definition, so let's see what happens,
so, even if one is false, so we drop the one.
Even if 2 is true, so pull the 2 out front
and filter over what's left.
Now, we've destructured the umer end to map
so we can pull that 2 through squaring functions,
we structured the upper end to take, can pull
that expression out front, three minus what's
left, levering with two, one value through
the list all the way through the pipeline.
We do more time.
We come down to take one, and one more time
again, we come down to take zero and we have
three elements out front.
We know by definition, take of zero is an
empty list and the result pops out.
We didn't have to look at the rest of the
infinite list, we didn't have to care about
it.
That's really really powerful, skipping work
you don't need to do to get the result you
want.
Again, Tom ash worth summed it up nicely there
are two ways to combine transformations you
perform the first transformation on the whole
collection before moving on to the second
or perform all the transformations on the
first element of the collection before moving
on to the second.
Now the first version is how JavaScript deals
with array, filter the whole array and hand
that off to the map and the map maps over
the whole array, reiterates it over how ever
many operations you have, the second way is
the way Haskell deal was arrays
's nothing inherent about the data structure
that says you is to process them this way,
you can use either strategy.
Just as Haskll deals with lists as if they
were streams question can deal with streams
as if they're lists.
Streams they're big part of node programming
right.
Huge part of node programming, really node's
core feature, these streams.
So, do something a little Funky.
So, I'm going to make a classical map that
inherit from stream.platform, and transform
method is going to replay that function to
incoming chunk and push it.
Going to add a map method to stream.prototype
that pipes the stream through map transform,
it's a similar lair toy array.map, we're taking
a stream of As, and a function from A to B
and a stream of A to B.
Same operation, filter same way, predicate
function, and now we're going to push the
chunk, if the predicate is true for that chunk.
Take is going to be substance showuated with
a number and in the transform method we're
going to push the chunk if N is greater than
zero and then call N if it reaches zero, it
will mean all the streams that are feeding
into this will stop sending it data because
it's emitted end, doesn't want anymore data,
we can stop processioning when we have the
information we want.
That gets us lay citiness.
We have split‑‑ Laziness.
I'm going to add the split modules to the
prototype.
Set high water mark 0 on all the streams,
that means node won't egg eerily buffer data
the streams don't need, it will pull data
through as it needs.
Put in a file called Lazy.Commonwealth of
Virginia fee, I can split the on‑line breaks
and filter those lines if cluster finishing
and map those matches to upper case and take
one of them.
And if I attach a data list to that I will
get the first class definition that comes
out as upper case, if you watch the filter
and the map functions here, they'll only be
called as many times as necessary to produce
the output, the program won't consume the
whole file, it's powerful.
You're letting the consumer of the operation
dictate how much get read at the other end,
you're avoiding work you don't need to do.
So here we're programming the streams and
they look like arrays, it might look like
a cute trick, it's a general model of programming,
general functional programming, I'm going
to write an IRC client using this strategy,
first I'll write it imperative so it's familiar
Irc is going to take a TCP socket stand in
and out, in a log file, we're going to split
the TCP and put on‑line breaks, IRC is a
line warranted protocol, going to write that
file to the logs, going to pause the line
into a‑‑ park it into a command structure,
if it's a notice we'll print to screen.
All the client will do is receive notices
from the server and print them.
These are also wants to join rim,es so we'll
split standard I believee input on‑line
break and if we see a line slash join, we
set our global variable room to the value
of the Redux match and construct an Irc command,
the Irc command for joining that rim.
If we did manager to construct a command,
then we'll unparse it turn it into a string
and write that string to TCP and we'll write
it to the logs.
We also want to send messages so if we oar
in a room and the line is not blank we'll
construct a proof message command ILC speak
for sending a mission age somewhere with the
room and the line of input, that's the room
that we're currently in, we always send a
message to the room we're currently in.
We want to receive messages from the server,
we'll get the channel and the message out
of that command and then compare the channel
to the room that we're currently in, if they
match, we'll display the line, so we're only
going to display messages from the server
from the room that we're currently in instead
of all the rooms we've joined.
There's what room we're in, there's conditional
processing, side effects things being written
to, event listeners, this is the imperative
style for solving this problem.
Programs like this tend to not scale very
well, the bigger they get, the harder it is
to reason want is happening at which times,
which is important you've written in a state.
Way.
So, write that functionally, we can write
function that takes TCP input stream and user
input stream and returns synchronously a TCP
output stream and user output stream and some
logs, rather than taking it all as input and
returning nothing with side effects we take
the inputs and return the outputs and do this
without using call backs.
How is that going to work.
We take Irc in equals TCP map,‑‑ take
a stream of strings mapping them through a
pausing function and that gives a string of
IRC objects, just like working with arrays,
pretend you're working with arrays, that's
what's going to happen, to get the notices,
we can filter those commands for one who's
command is notice, then match map the matches
and assign the notices to user out here.
And that means user out will be the formated
notice commands from the TCP stream.
And for the logs, we're just going to say
the logs are the TCP input for formatting
function.
We want to join room, add more code, say room
s is the user input, mapped through a function
that does a reject match on each line of input,
it's going to match/join with a rename, we're
going to filter the reduction matches, so
we just get the lines thattingually matched
and we're going to match those matches to
pull the room value out of the‑‑ now
we have a stream of rooms that we've join
joined to tell the server about that we need
need fro deuce a join command, join command
equals room.map to produce an IRC command.
And then to send those to the server, we can
say TCP out, equals joint command IRC, we
oar taking this stream of joint commands here,
mapping them to strings and assigning that
to the TCP output, I'm also merging the TCP
output into the logs here, time taking stuff
from input and stuff from out put and combining
them in really clean way to get my logs, instead
of putting logging logic at different point
in the program as before.
Now, we want to be able to send messages,
to send a message you need the room you're
currently in, and you fled message you want
to send, we try dog this without states, there's
no global room variable (Need) instead of
what we do user end out filter for lines that
aren't blank and we do this thing rooms.sampled
by, whatever messages‑‑ event, it gets
the latest vent by rooms and give both of
the values by function arguments and construct
an IRC out of them, and then, we can just
merge those into the TCP output with the joins
that we're sending earlier.
So ...
finally we want to be able to receive messages
from other people.
So, we're going to filter the incoming messages
for ones that match prove messages, and again,
we're going to use sample by, so every time
we get a message in, we're going to give the
room we're currently in, and the message we
just got, and compare the room that we're
currently if to the message room parameter,
this gives us a stream of Boole cranes to
tell us whether the message we just got is
for the room that we're currently in, it's
slightly weird operation, but it does work.
And then I can filter the in‑coming messages
on that stream, if you have a stream of Boole
cranes you can use that to filter something
else.
This will give you a stream of the in‑coming
messages for the room I'm currently in, I've
written a non‑trivial network application
that does exactly what we had before, no side
effects no variables are my stated, no call
backs in the sense of side effect functions
that return nothing.
It's all pure functions, you can replace any
variable variable in the program with a definition
and the program will do exactly the same thing,
there's no hidden state to take care of, rather
than write ago program that says do this,
then do this, you've written a program that
defines streame streams of day the relative
to other streams of data and the control flow
is implicit that makes it easier to work in
current programs.
To sum up you can get the slides here.
The article that Tom Ashwroth wrote.
‑‑ similarities between promises and
liveses and maybes and stuff like that and
how they compos, last year Phillip Roberts
is giving a talk here tomorrow, gave a really
good talk ant real‑timeCONF that you need
watch.
And I've ended that with the links to documentation
for some of these streaming libraries that
I've use in the this talk.
Finally, I thought I'd try and do something
nice while I'm here, earlier this year I wrote
this book, apparently it's quite good, if
you use the code JSFST for this weekend you
can get fiver pounds off of it, and it's already
half price.
thank you for having me.
And I well see you upstairs (Applause)